[Music]
all right big news 9 tonight judge Brett
Kavanaugh has now been nominated by
President Trump to the US Supreme Court
by the way Sarah Sanders just told
reporters that the White House expects
him to be confirmed by October the 1st
joining us now more reaction fox news
contributor sebastian Gorka this book up
there the Russia hoax is out in two
weeks that's right the illicit scheme to
clear Hillary Clinton frame Donald Trump
proud of you for that all right real
quick let's get your reaction and the
fear-mongering that's already begun and
it would have been for any nominee of
the president Dick Durbin smeared and
led the smear campaign against Cavanaugh
12 years ago calling Cavanaugh the
Forrest Gump of Republican politics
which only underscores how obtuse and
partisan Durbin is it didn't work then
it's not going to work now and the left
is already conjuring up the hysteria
claiming that this means abortion will
be outlawed in America that's simply
untrue even if you overturn roe v wade
and i doubt that happens but if it does
that means the decision reverts back to
the states what that's such an important
point by the way because that would knee
York New Jersey 5 6 7 8 states are not
gonna they might have different views on
it different restrictions first three
months parental consent all sorts but
they were going to be very liberal
states it does not mean that abortion is
going to be outlawed lie perpetuated by
persuaded by the left and and that's all
true let me ask a political question dr.
Gorka this now if again the White House
says they expect him confirmed by
October 1st leading into this very
important midterm election that does
mean a couple of things not the least of
which red state Senate Democrats Manchin
Claire McCaskill Heidi Heitkamp Tilda
Nelson they've got themselves one really
tough decision to make dick Durbin is
telling them Oh risked your entire
political career and he said it before
the nomination was even announced yes I
look the the reaction already Gregg's
absolutely right is all you need to know
about Cavanaugh the fact that the DNC
has already stated that this man
shouldn't be anywhere close to the
Supreme Court the fact
Chuck Schumer has just announced that he
will use every weapon in his arsenal to
stop this nomination last week before he
was nominated souls that's shocking
right right right so this tells you that
this is the right man for the job but it
tells you that November is going to be
very very tough for the Democrats I just
want to make sure the White House is
listening bill shrine this is going to
be a very important communications
message because this is going to be
worse than Bork I give you the
prediction now they will use every dirty
trick in the book to block this
nomination but we can't get it through I
played Ted Kennedy with Robert Bork it
was despicable what that was the
Chappaquiddick who is a disgrace to the
US Senate and then what they did to
Clarence Thomas was a disgrace to the US
Senate absolutely but it's gonna happen
sure I've been saying this since for
weeks it's predictable and it doesn't
matter who presidents from would have
nominated the same smears would have
occurred but I admire president Truong
he had the courage to make the right
choice
notwithstanding the fact that he could
have chosen somebody who would have been
an easier confirmation but no he made an
important choice the right choice a
brilliant jurist there's no question
what I read to you about what his
judicial philosophy what he said he's a
textualist when it comes to statutes an
originalist when it comes to the
Constitution he is younger beyond the
court let alone Gregg Jarrett no doubt
whatsoever 300 opinions plus prove it no
okay so that this is why I keep saying
dr. Gork oh we have less than a minute
this 2018 midterm election is the most
important in our lifetime all those
Senate seats that that could change
hands and become Republican the
Republicans have a very slim margin and
that means Rand Paul Ted Cruz that means
susan collins and lisa murkowski
in that sense that the president make
the right call I think he did I think he
absolutely did you heard the two
sentences he made in the East Room he
said we I do not believe
in legislation I believe that we
interpret the law we don't legislate it
and the Constitution is to be
interpreted not amended that tells you
everything we need to know about 2018 is
even more important than 2016 Sean you
know as judge school Scalia once
famously said a good judge will make
many considerations as the law demands
that they make dislike